we've got a zombie war on drugs now
you know we've had 50 years it's been a
failure we've now had our last year
record overdose debt in the united
states
the level of violence in latin america
has been
in the last 20 years there's been more
than 2 million homicides in latin
america
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is a
mexican-based journalist and the author
of several books about the war on drugs
including this latest one blood gun
money john gorilla welcome to
trigonometry great to be here it's great
to have you man we're so excited as you
know about speaking with you this is an
issue we were really keen to talk about
before we get into all that stuff tell
us a little bit about who you are how
are you where you are you've had a very
interesting journey through your life
haven't you
well i'm originally from from the uk
grew up just near brighton um did a few
bit of a checkered uh few things i did
uh before i get into journalism i
played in a punk band for a bit around
the brighton area i was involved in
pirate radio in london for a bit
and at 27 i went over to mexico uh to
get into journalism
originally with a bit of romantic ideas
of like you know running around with
grillers fighting you know fighting
military dictatorships and stuff
arrived in mexico in the year 2000 um
when things had changed very much and
very early on fell into covering drugs
issue of drugs
i grew up in the southeast with a lot of
drugs around then a bit of an opioid
epidemic back then in the 80s
i knew about four teenagers or young men
who died of heroin overdoses
around those times so it kind of
interested me connecting this issue of
drug use countries and communities that
use a lot of drugs
and countries which traffic um and
produce drugs
and we just fascinated the beginning
with this kind of glamour and the
riddles of the mexican drug cartels
so i was covering this a lot and while i
was there covering this it just blew up
really from 2008 2006 the government
launched a military crackdown on cartels
2008 was when the violence really
exploded and it became like a
a weird hybrid armed conflict i mean
insane things happening
i found myself in situations i couldn't
have imagined i found myself like in a
mall with 49 bodies that had all been
decapitated all had their hands and feet
cut off
found myself just dealing with a really
crazy situation in the country
really bleeding a lot of pain um i
thought i couldn't get this out just in
news reports so i wrote a first book
about this which turned into a trilogy
of books about this
traveled around latin america looking at
how this was playing out across the
continent brazil
venezuela colombia honduras jamaica
up into the u.s itself seeing this
um and i've been i've been doing that
since really uh you know and i've now
got more to doing some sort of tv series
as well
um but still out here right away living
as a journalist
it's great to have you on to talk about
all this stuff and there's obviously so
much we could talk about but we always
like to start with the very basics for
anyone who's coming to this conversation
for the first time might not know much
about it what is the drug war the war on
drugs as we talk what is it
yes so
if you look at drug trafficking in the
modern sense okay it goes actually all
the way back
to
1914
you had a thing in the u.s called the
harrison's narcotic tax act
um where they started
taxing like some and and regulating and
prohibiting some
opium and cocaine back then in 1914 1915
it came into effect because prior to
this you could just buy it yes i mean
there was some like local measures came
in
um but like very early on then from like
1915 when it started to really be like
more national kind of drug prohibition
or kind of regulation you had a drug
trade from mexico to the united states
so there's a case you can look at going
back to 1916 of cases of people
trafficking drugs from mexico to the
united states initially it was often
chinese immigrants to mexico obviously
we had the opium war you know us brits
uh forced uh the the sailing of opium in
china the habits continued people moved
to mexico started planting opium in
mexico
and trafficking it to chinese americans
some of the very first cases you can see
in 1916 and right back then there was
mexican governors involved in the
corruption so you saw this kind of thing
then the real war on drugs happens
under richard nixon the date is
generally seen as being in 1971 when
richard nixon president richard nixon
had this press conference where he said
um public enemy number one in the united
states is illegal drugs
and he had you know we're going to fight
a war against them a war on drugs
and
he talked in very absolutist terms in
those days it was like we will have an
abolition of drugs from american life
like there will be no heroin um you know
middle class parents don't worry about
your kids taking heroin it's not going
to happen there will be no heroin
available
that was 1971 then you saw this
escalation
um the drug trade in colombia really
kicking off the violence in colombia you
know escobar
cocaine and drug habits in the united
states really really increasing the drug
consumption
reagan amped it up
and then you've had this since then now
i say now argue now
that really we've got a zombie war on
drugs now because
that you know like you know like that
what you know we've had 50 years it's
been a failure we've now had our last
year record overdose debt in the united
states
the level of violence in latin america
has been
in the last 20 years there's been more
than 2 million homicides in latin
america more than 2 million murders so
the level of violence now a lot of this
when you see it on the ground is more
actually like an armed conflict you're
covering i mean these are heavily armed
groups
military crackdowns by governments
um so you've seen a lot more death there
than than most of the middle east
um
and
a large amount is related to
cocaine trade not not obviously not all
the murders but a large that's a large
factor in this violence there
um but there isn't really any more the
impetus the kind of real energy of
people about let's try and stop drugs
being in people's lives they kind of
accept and live with drugs now
but we still have this kind of
prohibition stumbling on
elements and this kind of enforcement
and so forth and john it seems quite
clear to me and i think to most people
that the war on drugs simply doesn't
work can you explain number one why it
doesn't and the effects it has on these
types of communities
yeah sure so
um if you look at um drugs okay let's
take cocaine is one of the ones which is
uh interesting to look at
and so people make uh killer cocaine
first it starts off with a bunch of
leaves uh from you know coca leaves in
colombia peru bolivia colombia is the
biggest producer
about 80 someone will get for like
harvesting a bunch of leaves some like
you know peasant farmer down in a
campesino down in colombia
eventually goes through two chemical
processes it becomes a kilo brick of
cocaine which they'll stamp you know
with their with their label on
and that sells
depending on where in colombia you buy
if you buy in the countryside it's
cheaper
you know it could be about two thousand
dollars buying it for for export
bounces up to the us
you know even the
southern us
wholesale you're talking about forty
thousand dollars
on the streets
a hundred thousand dollars plus plus you
cut it up with a bunch of crap
and then you make it double two hundred
thousand hundred thousand dollars so the
profits for that are just insane i mean
we know we're all in the in the [ __ ]
business of journalism
i was about to say we're in the wrong
business yeah yeah and we're like
imagine any kind of business where you
could like anyone who wants to kind of
business and think if i flip you know
most businesses you might see i have 20
markups imagine that you're saying this
is what drug dealers it's the way they
talk
okay you're gonna and i'm gonna put in
you know 100 grand and i'm expecting to
make
half a million out of that you know at
least it's like you know you're making
so much money you know or more i mean
you look at think of the markups on that
level
so you get
such an incentive
for anyone to do this so what happens it
doesn't take a rocket scientist to do
this
you know it's buying products selling
products moving products
so most violent people are often going
to succeed in this
or people using calculated violence
calculate corruption so you end up in
mexico with
psychopathic
cartels in the way the stuff they do i
mean the stuff so you know you covered
there you know i've covered there is
is insane i mean like this mass covered
a mass grave with
the remains of 298 people
and that was right next to a housing
estate and as they were uncovering it
that the week of that death the week of
the bodies was then wreaking out they
were complaining about what we we've got
kids playing in the gardens here we've
got the smell of death coming
i mean that's what it leads to but
anyway why doesn't work is i think that
not my amount of incentive
and you arrest people but doesn't you
know someone else will take their place
and you know chapel himself will say
this you know they said this when when
he was
um he gave a video
um statement and he said like
i'm not the only one doing this those
people involved in drug trafficking and
that's true so anyone's going to take
their place all people keep on taking
their place can keep on doing it
and unless you know and and the
governments in the west are not prepared
for like a really authoritarian
crackdown that could stop it like if it
was a really authoritarian crackdown
like saying anybody we see with drugs
we're going to execute right away and
cut your head off
then that might stop it but just saying
we're going to lock people up in prison
you know they're always going to find
more people willing to traffic drugs
and
the one thing that i always struggle
because you know we talk to politicians
on the show sometimes or journalists or
people
messages who are quite influential in
government or elsewhere the one thing i
always struggle to get people
to understand is why this matters
here
why why should anyone care about this
yeah
i think two two reasons i mean one the
first reason which
it might be hard to convince people but
you know you should care about what
you're connected to one of the things
about drugs and i find fascinating is
you know you could somebody you could be
somebody could be snorting a line of
cocaine in a toilet in
in london
and that has a journey
that money you spent on that
that gram some of that money is going to
reach
these cartels so you actually got
responsibility for caring about where
that goes some of that money goes to
paying a hit man who's carrying out
those massacres who's cutting up those
bodies who's leaving like you know kids
disappeared and a bunch of brutal stuff
it's not just bad guys
being taken out there's a lot of
innocent people who have died in this so
one you should care but that's hard no
it's quite a hard sell right i mean our
phones are made in pretty much the same
way yeah yeah it's quite a hard sell
people say like well you know should you
try and have a campaign
don't take cocaine because it goes you
know people you know like in some pub
and someone's drunk and someone comes to
offering it's hard to kind of think
but the other thing is
what i've seen over the last 20 years in
latin america and mexico it's like
a new type of
armed conflict a new type of violence
and you see how this can play out in the
21st century and how bad what this could
mean for society it's totally changed
the way i think i grew up here in the uk
i would not like police you know as a
teenager it's a punk teenager i'd be
like anti-police and stuff
um
now you see how horrific
crime can be how this can affect a
society what that means in terms of
quality of life standard of life for
people when
you know somebody's
daughter is disappeared and then
brutally raped and murdered
when you know you have a
a mother who's a school teacher who
describes her 18 year old son who's a
philosophy student being taken away by
an armed group from her house and just
disappeared and she's going around
morgues trying to find his only sign of
him
these kind of things now i know we're a
long way from that now
but i do see in this country and in
europe
society getting more fragmented um you
know like these kind of
divisions and stuff and we shouldn't
take for granted
because we've had
a fairly non-violent society for for
many years it's always going to be the
case because historically we're just as
violent in europe or you know as
anywhere else
so what what is the solution to the war
on drugs it looks like the authority
we're not going to do a complete like
like they've got in the philippines
where someone who's found with a bag of
coke essentially gets executed
this crackdown doesn't work so what is
the solution
i think i mean i uh advocate for drug
policy reform you know use that phrase i
mean like drug policy because
legalization
is
i mean it is more complicated than just
the word legalization
because actually when you get you know
into drug policy you realize it's not
just a button you press and it all stops
um yes you have to get into like nitty
and gritty of drug policy and stuff so
drug policy reform i i see as as
representing saying the current
policies don't work we have to reform
and reshape this and look for ways now
part of that
means
uh elements of legalization so i'm in in
favor of legalizing marijuana i think
the uk is behind it i think uk should
legalize marijuana for a lot of reasons
i mean there's reasons of why should
somebody be be arrested why should there
be you know gangs making money from
selling weed which is an incentive and
then drives violence and all kinds of
stuff
um still today um
you know you have these really violent
cartels in mexico
still now it's a lot less now because of
legalization in the states but they're
still moving some some weed now
you still have
um the most you know the most violent
players
growing a bunch of marijuana trafficking
in the united states um in baltimore
there's still people selling weed on the
street corners there and people getting
shot over that
so legalizing marijuana and then we have
to get into a
very difficult discussion about what we
do with heroin cocaine
crystal meth
um
fentanyl which is
other things
it's a difficult discussion i don't know
the the answers one thing i do think we
need to look at
we can agree on is we need to really
take rehab very seriously
um particularly in the us but in the uk
as well um we are very sorry fragmented
societies i mean why in the u.s is
there's so much drug addiction
why are people hurting so much
and and according to the american
medical association only 10 of people
who need addicts who need rehab are
getting it so you've got ninety percent
you've got a huge amount of work just to
try and offer people the help they need
if and for every
addict you get off heroin that's a lot
of heroin they buy because addicts are
buying a lot all the time now i do
realize it gets into difficult things
about cocaine you know how you know how
we try and move on on cocaine on heroin
and crystal meth but we've got to start
having a conversation about this yeah i
agree and it's interesting as well what
people assume when you start
seeking practical solutions to this
because from my perspective i've never
tried cocaine and i i don't want to i've
never done any hard drugs it's not
something that
not something that appeals to me because
i've got morals
but
but seriously though but i also think
you need to have a practical approach
right and whatever we're doing now is
just not working and one of the ways you
see that is what's been happening in
mexico which you've been covering for a
long time i mean from what i understand
and correct me on this mexico has
essentially not run by any it's run by
the cartels most of the money that's
made in mexico is in some way connected
to the drug trade is that broadly
accurate that's that's a probably a bit
of an overstatement yeah um but like
i mean the situation is is horrific and
at a local level that's true
um i'll give you an example um so so the
carter we don't know the exact amount of
money it's very you know because it's a
black market
but you know the estimates it could be
say 30 billion dollars of money from
trafficking drugs to the united states
now mexico is a trillion dollar economy
you know mexico is not a poor country
it's a mid-income country with
with rich people and poor people and
we're in the middle
but that's 30
then goes it's very concentrated in
certain communities so you have certain
areas certain cities and neighborhoods
certain villages where drugs where drug
money is the biggest thing
but then that
money helps pollutant corrupt the entire
system and a breakdown and as a level
one time
i was in a town on the border
and um
we were the cartel located i was unh
unhappy we were there
um the world was going to they were
telling local journalists you know we're
not happy about journalists who's
snooping around being here
so eventually we had a talk with the
cartel with a cartel representative a
cartel guy from there who came to our
hotel with ak-47 in the back of his car
um first thing we've done when you're
filming here blah blah blah you talk to
him
and and you know kind of level stuff out
say oh yeah you can leave
me you'll be fine don't worry
and he said if you have any problems
with the police you call me
that shows who runs the local police
force
i mean and it's that's that's the level
of insanity i mean you literally see
cops
um
i've seen cops who have you know
actually carrying cocaine in their car
which they're running for the cartel who
have like cartel issued um guns
um
the level even more so there was you
know a case in which i can of a police
officer a few years ago his name was
tyson after the boxer kind of guy and he
was
caught and gave a forced confession
for the federal government
but in that confession he was describing
not only working for the cartel
not only murdering people for the cartel
um but being a ranking cartel member and
training
young cartel affiliates how to like
butcher victims how to cut off limbs
so that's the level when you have police
force
police force is doing that imagine what
law enforcement is like in those areas
and how bad it is now in terms of you
know
you know as you get into mexico concept
of like narco state you know is it
become a narco state at that point and
then you've got presidents i mean right
now a guy who was the
um
former
um public security secretary you know he
was the really one of the leading
figures in the war on drugs i'd
interviewed him before
um kind of guy with a big big kind of
square jaw kind of talked a good game
um
isn't he currently imprisoned in the
united states on drug trafficking
charges
so like that's the level of corruption
now you say it's a narcos state
but then it gets more complicated
because at the same time
you know you say well the entire state
is illegitimate now it's all drug
traffickers but then it gets more
complicated because then you have okay
you still have doctors who are working
very very hard fighting covid you still
have teachers who are working hard
trying you know trying to teach kids you
still have people running electricity
collecting rubbish all of these things
the state is doing
more functionally it's not like we're
saying an area where the islamic state
controls or in latin america the
cinderella luminosa the shining path in
peru where they control the whole area
and they're very interested in changing
the way people think and like changing
and turning them into you know into
maoist communists or islamic state into
like islamists extreme islamists
the drug cartel controlling area
they don't really care what the school's
doing
what they care about is controlling the
police force controlling the rackets but
they've got the drugs but they're also
into
extortion kidnapping prostitution
stealing oil
illegal mining and a whole bunch of
other things so you see a real breakdown
a kind of like a warlordism i think a
lot of the world is suffering this kind
of challenge to authority as well
hey francis do you want to learn another
language no mike i'm english if
foreigners can't understand me i just
shout at them think about it you could
learn how to say penalties in italian
leave it but if you do want to learn
another language because maybe you want
to have new experiences live in another
country or maybe you just want to open
your mind my mind's open enough if i
open it up any further my brain's gonna
hurt this is true but babel's 15-minute
lessons make it the perfect way to learn
a new language on the go they design
their courses with practical real-world
conversations in mind sentences will use
in normal everyday life sentences like
oi pedro dos services paul favor thank
you francis and bible's courses have
been proven to be scientific
and bible's courses have been proven to
be scientifically effective across
multiple studies their 15-minute lessons
make it the perfect way to learn a new
language on the go it's available as an
app or online and your progress will be
synced across all devices you can choose
from 14 different languages including
spanish french italian and german
they've also got their own podcast so
you can brush up on your french and
spanish on the go start your new
language learning journey today with
babel and before you know it
espanol absolutamente perfecto now i
mean gary right now babel is offering
our listeners six months free with a
purchase of a six month subscription
with our promo code which is of course
trigger go to uk dot babble dot com
slash play and use promo code trigger
for an extra six months free that's uk
dot b a b b e l dot c o m forward slash
play promo code trigger
[Music]
and john is it do they have that kind of
relationship that escort had with the
colombian people whereby the colombian
people loved him because you know he
gave them schools he provided them
resources he helped a very very poor
people or is it far more oppressive than
that
so it's a very mixed bag and i've been
up to the village where el chapo's from
um met his his mother interviewed his
mother sat through a three-hour
evangelical service christian service
his mom's an evangelical christian in a
church that he built
um he built a paved road in that town
and you know it's a small town he's
obviously very very popular there it's
all you know
in that area um and everyone's into the
cartel
um and they they talk about these
communities they talk about them they
call them valientes or brave ones
and they look up to them but then also
you get a lot of people who see well you
know these people are like demons these
people have
um you know they you know a lot of this
is a big movement in mexico particularly
of mothers whose
children um sons and daughters
have been murdered um in in violence
they often buy cartel by armed groups or
by the corrupt police working with the
cartels or by the soldiers fighting the
cartels or the marines someone is just
like you know mayhem out there
and they're like going around trying to
find
um you know the bodies of their loved
ones and there's one woman
who who i interviewed in the state of
veracruz
who was actually helped find that
biggest grave i mentioned earlier of 298
bodies she helped find it looking for
her son
after four years of looking for her son
she found that mass grave
and after two more years the dna of one
of the bodies was traced to her son
so she had that closure so you've got
this level of mass disappearances
now it gets complicated it's mixed with
cartels mixed with the corrupt
government so people are like
you know what's actually who we fighting
with the cartels or the police
because they're like conspiring together
um but yeah you've got that kind of
mixed thing but you still have you know
the people look up to cartels as well
and as you know
um during the covert they were handing
out bags of goodies you know the
beginning covid when all the lock down
happened they were handing out these
plastic bags of goodies of rice and eggs
and good products and you know getting
their loyalty from people um at the same
time and we seem to have seen
particularly in mexico an
intensification that you referred to
since i think 2006 was it yeah i think
the 2000 yeah 2016.
yeah so there was a real big crackdown
under president calderon
uh
you would have thought the the
government of a pretty big country with
support from the united states at the
time as well cracking down using the
military using full the full force of
the state to deal with this would have
had a positive impact on dealing with it
and yet what we've seen seems to be been
the opposite
how has that happened sure i think i
think two big reasons
um
one is the a lot of the
military are corrupt
in fact one of the cartel was actually a
special forces unit yeah wasn't it
and i've interviewed one of the guys who
was a military guy and was in in that
from early on so yeah you had these
um soldiers
like hardcore soldiers who then flipped
to the cartel
and
so that's the equivalent of like the sas
yeah flipping to become a drug
trafficking organization initially they
were the enforcement arm and then they
formed their own cartel and then and
they they really you could say they were
the ones who militarize the conflict
right because when it um and i was
covering this first covering this as a
young journalist worked for the houston
chronicle
in the states and as this was kind of
playing out and you saw the violence was
really up it used to be like
gang bangers as they say you know the us
guys in fact it was america they'd have
some of these american like
mexican-american gang bangers would come
over and be hired by the cartels before
guys with shaved heads tattoos like
pistols
like you know shooting and stuff
and then the setas were like no no you
know we're going to do violence a
different way we like ak-47s uh
bulletproof jackets male helmets radios
organizing so one of these early things
i covered there was a bunch of these
gang members were sent to fight them
and they killed them all part them up
they brought us up in a house and put a
message saying you know send us some
some more bendecos like these so we can
kill them
pendejos meaning you know send us some
more idiots like these so we can kill
them but also the military carried out
being corrupt you know there was you
know
recently a case of a general um who was
arrested in the united states flew into
the united states was arrested event you
know charged on drug trafficking they
dropped the charge and sent him back to
mexico i covered a trial of two
court martial of two generals who are
convicted on drug trafficking so there's
no you know it's not a big secret it's
you know the military themselves can be
corrupt they can be very very violent
but also
if you look at it from a street to
strategic point of view and i think the
government underestimated the threat
there was in mexico in 2006 when it
launched the crackdown
it's not like one cartel in mexico's
loads of cartels
all over the country
so you start sending in the military to
one place
and fighting a cartel and it starts
kicking off somewhere else
then the cartels start fighting back so
like as well so they're fighting the
military which might be even allied to a
different cartel and they start
ambushing soldiers ambushing police
kidnapping police leaving the bodies of
police you know kidnapping marines uh
there's one case where some marines were
tricked by some local police who were
affiliated to the
to the to the settlers cartel that same
cartel
in into going to a bar without their
weapons were kidnapped and tortured and
murdered on video so suddenly they're
like you know you're cracking down on us
we're gonna use violence to press you to
back off
so you suddenly started having more of a
confident escalation of the conflict so
now you've got
i mean there was a situation in 2019
when the
some members of the police in the
military attempted to arrest a son of el
chapo
in kulikan
and of course according to a military
account of this
700 to 800 gunmen took to the streets
cartel gunman wow
to put pressure to liberate him against
350 soldiers
they eventually that day under orders
from the government and the military
themselves felt betrayed but the
government said he let him go
because people were terrified that it's
going to start massacring everyone
they're out on the streets they were
using 50 cows firing so again i mean it
looks like it looks like an armed
conflict it looks like so basically to
put that in context i just like a lot of
people in the west i don't think
understand what we're talking about
that's the equivalent of a major drug
dealer's son let's say in london or in
liverpool or in new york or in baltimore
being arrested yeah
then nearly a thousand people armed with
military-grade weapons are on the
streets and the government is like oh
you know what to avoid further violence
we're gonna let them go yeah exactly
that's what happened exactly exactly
what happened yeah very well put um yeah
yeah no no no no no no it's a good way
to try and get that through to people
when you because people do see this as
being some like place you can't really
relate to yeah to try and say imagine
this stuff happening in in in england or
whatever in the u.s
um and you know imagine you know there
being
you know mass graves in fields next to
an estate in coventry or something yeah
and suddenly start digging up and found
like you know 200 bodies there um what
that means
for society when that happens
but isn't there also a fundamental
hypocrisy in that we've got america you
know the uk lecturing you know
about drugs the evil of drugs yeah they
did a cocaine swab test in the toilet
the house of parliament it came out
positive yeah yeah yeah yeah absolutely
yeah um yeah i mean it's complete
hypocrisy that's what we have to talk
about and i don't i don't know
you know can we legalize cocaine i don't
know the solution to that um often when
i do talks about this i'll ask people
say who's in favor of legalizing
marijuana you know most places i've got
a majority will put her hands up i say
who who's in favor of legalizing cocaine
just to get the reaction from people and
so i don't know totally the answer to
this um but you often get a few people
now kind of i mean account what can we
do with cocaine i mean cocaine is not
as lethal as
heroin um
or crystal meth um but can you legalize
it could there be a place you know could
you get it off license and also go and
say i'll have you know a six pack of
lager and a couple of grams of you know
colombia's finest or or not i don't know
if you're in
i liverpool know but right yeah but
right now it's happening anyway so right
now the fact is you go to the pub as a
there's a guy who's who's selling
cocaine and it's gonna cut up with crap
yeah so you've got more danger as well
of people having you know like wherever
it's gonna you know stuff they could
have put with it and in mexico there's
people selling i'm you know just in a
town we're working and there was a
closing of a political event in fact and
there was a van on the side
and there was people just serving up
cocaine there i've been in the fabelas
in brazil
on a table just selling
you know oh yeah would you want cocaine
they've got like little bags with the
numbers there cocaine crack and the guys
are openly there with you know with
guns with rocket launchers on us with a
grenade launcher as well
um so yeah i mean it's happening anyway
the drug trade is happening now we're
not stopping it so yeah we have to try
and think about a better way out of this
and this is a question i think many
people probably don't
understand the answer to and i to some
extent don't am i right i'm thinking
that the reason mexico is such a such a
violent place because of drugs is
because it's the it's the trafficking
point to the united states which is the
biggest market for illegal drugs in the
world
why are all these drugs made in latin
america why they produced there yeah
so so yeah it was exactly right i mean
the united states has the biggest uh
drug consumption in the world by far
um again we don't know the real numbers
um but there's estimates put out by the
the rand corporation they have like
um
uh
they put out commission by the white
house it's called what americans spend
on illegal drugs
estimates about 150 billion dollars
every year that americans are spending
on illegal drugs so so imagine that
you're next door in mexico you're the
biggest providers for this
um
cocaine has only cut so coca is
originally from
the andes area that's the tradition
where the plants are from you still have
groups in colombia more so in bolivia
using indigenous communities using the
plants they just chew it as like like we
take coffee or something they chew it
they're ceremonies as well the
ceremonies used with i went up to see
the coke fields in in colombia in a an
area there and i went up with this one
indigenous group
and it's interesting because this group
was had a bunch of ex
farc they had various paramilitaries
there and i had this indigenous group
who took me up to to see it and they
simply they didn't have guns and that is
staff
and their thing was if they were ever
like challenged they would like raise
this staff and then loads of them come
out and like so it was actually good
security and it's kind of like you know
it sounds like something out of avatar
yeah yeah yeah
but no but they they were taught what
they had these they have they actually
allowed someone to grow coker for you
know even in colombia
then so you know so the plants
originally from there historically
and
it hasn't taken up there was an effort a
few years ago to try and produce cocaine
in nigeria
and it didn't really take off there's
been little efforts even within like
there's been little efforts of like
guatemala mexico to make cocaine but
really it's the andes you know the the
the climate the conditions for growing
coca leaves
heroin can be made in a lot of countries
um but mexico's got good conditions and
it's right you know right next to the
united states and same with marijuana
and now with the synthetic drugs so
crystal meth fentanyl so now they make
fentanyl in mexico or they're bringing
fentanyl and mix it up with heroin
what is fentanyl by the way yeah
fentanyl is um so you've got the big
class of drugs called opioids or opiates
um which uh opium based things which are
like um downers people say they kind of
bring you down
very good painkillers and that's the
biggest real addiction problem in the
united states is really these
opiates are the
the the biggest really for deaths
because the level between what you can
take and your body can survive with an
overdose is much closer than with
cocaine or some other drugs or or
marijuana i mean it's important so it's
very easy to od on it easy od on it
um and
nowadays you've got i mean you've had
through the pharmaceutical industry and
you've got a lot of corruption really in
the united states of people prescribing
um opiates i mean it's been gone for a
long time i mean i got friends here in
the uk
who got addicted to heroin after going
into hospital and being given you know
down as then it's going back to the 80s
but in the us there was like big pushing
from the drug companies
to like yeah prescribe them um you know
like describe my opiates prescribe them
you know make money out of this you know
and a lot of people making money and
then people are hooked and then they're
buying it illegally so then the cartels
start also making getting these formulas
making it going to countries buying
precursors making it themselves so now
there's a big amount of money you can
make you don't need to be in the
mountains growing opium leaves or coca
leaves you just got a lab somewhere
bringing some precursors um you know you
know you know bribe customs or like
sneak them through
um and this in a lab right by the board
or any place and be making making these
uh opiates or crystal meth as well
it seems to me that you know drugs are
so prevalent in america and the uk and
look this is me with my tinfoil hat
please disavow me of this idea
but they're not people really high up
who've got their fingers in this pie
because i just think to myself it can't
be so prevalent and people
up top know what's going on or don't
know what's going on
yeah it's an interesting idea like you
know sometimes i i'll try and put you
know write up eds and try and be like
end the war on drugs um do this you know
can and just trying to push for real
solutions because i get very frustrated
now i feel like politics is broken yeah
and i feel this is something we can fix
you know a lot of things we can't fix
you know we're not going to be able to
find common ground on but this is
something we should be able to fix it's
like wrong and can't we find a better
way it's like why they're not doing it
you know so i try and put forward
optimistic things whoever it is biden
administration you know boris john
anything you know just move forward in
this policy and everyone says you know
then people be like ah you're so naive
you know there's a bunch of people
making a big money on this
they want this kind of disorder
i don't know i mean my dad used to say
um you have
conspiracy theory and you have the
cock-up theory
and often i will first look at the
cock-up theory yeah
but then also you have the cocked up
conspiracy theory
so you have like stuff that can be like
you know are there interests there of
people i mean certainly people
um you have got bureaucracies there so
you've got like the dea a couple of
billion dollars budget every year
they've got incentive to keep that
budget to keep it
they've got asset seizure
you know they're seizing you know drug
uh traffickers
can the biggest um
cash bust in the world ever was in
mexico 205 27 million dollars in cash in
a house in mexico
from a chinese guy actually bring in
precursors for crystal meth
that money is then asset seized by the
mexican government they have 27 million
dollars
um you know the u.s you know sees houses
of people and stuff and then use that
for
so yeah there are interests there and
people selling guns um to drug
traffickers uh people selling guns to
gangs that's a business
uh
banks hsbc was caught um big money
laundering case there um you've got
money coming in you know you're like i
knew i i talked to a guy a guy contacted
me who was selling
expensive watches
to drug traffickers um in colombia he
was a colombian guy based in miami but
he was going to to europe
and and he was selling like he was going
to colombia with like i mean we're
talking you know
really expensive watches hundred
thousand dollars a piece
going with a few of them go off to these
like rancid drug traffickers sell them a
few feel these watches
the watch companies are happy with that
you know he was their best seller
you know who can you find with that kind
of money to buy to buy watch so a lot of
people make money out of this and there
could be interests but i think also
there's a lot of just
broken politics
and we can't fix you know why can we not
fix anything more and why politicians
um now this is actually also linked to
the issue of refugees which another
reason actually your question about why
we should care yeah
right you know people flee
violence in latin america and then come
to the united states people flee
violence in africa and you know come to
europe
different sources different reasons
there but one of the reasons they're
driving this
so people arrive a lot of them have got
asylum claims that are very strong
saying you know they're threatened to
kill my entire family they're working
with the police if i go back they're
going to murder me
um that's driving people and
so you have to care because if you know
countries are in in cows it affects you
but then you get like
um you know so alejandro ocasio-cortez
tweet i know america was um
involved
in supporting governments in latin
america
um in central america in the 80s but how
about right now how about what's
happening right now and how you can
solve these practical things
but i think a lot of politics is more
about like posturing
than actually saying any kind of
pragmatic solution to these kind of
problems
that's what i find really odd about this
whole thing you know because it's like
many of the issues that we talk about
you know you know us you watch the show
we speak to people on the right and the
left we try and have that balanced
discussion
and the things that you just mentioned
the stuff that people in america let's
say on the right care about the border
the border security what they call if
you've got a continent of people who are
being murdered and raped and disappeared
and whatever a lot of them are going to
want to leave that and come to the
united states so if you fix this issue
you're going to solve that problem to to
a very significant extent uh likewise in
the uk i mean one of the things we've
been talking about a lot recently is
racial disparities over policing of
certain communities etc and a lot of
that is in my opinion down to the fact
that there's there's there's a lot of
people being criminalized for something
that they didn't they often
be criminalized for but if you create
the opportunity to make as much money as
you're saying for people who don't have
many other options that's what's going
to happen then the police have to come
in because of the violence and then you
know the 17 year old with a bag of weed
in his pocket is being treated in a very
different way to somebody who's got the
same bag of weed at oxford university
right so there's so there's so many
things that can be fixed by addressing
this issue
why do you think
that first of all politics you've
alluded to somewhere but also just you
know public sentiment isn't necessarily
on the side of what we're talking about
here
i mean i see a massive switch on the
drug issue over the last few years
i remember in 2010 i was on
charlie rose show before his demise
for her lives on the charlie rose show
and we were having discussion then and
charlie rose asked about uh drug
legalization legalization
and oh sorry 2012.
he asked about drug legalization and one
of the other guests in our journey said
oh it's a non-starter
um and
this is a sentiment i heard a lot in
older journalists you know drug drug
legalization is a non-starter you
mentioned it's just not going to happen
that year in 2012
they legalized cannabis first of all
washington state
and colorado and then it's you know it's
been spreading across legal recreational
marijuana so that's obviously on the
table now
um so you have seen and you seem like
you know just you know this last
election there was a whole bunch of
these um
other
votes in the united states and
mississippi
you know by a big percentage uh prove
legalizing medical marijuana so you've
seen a big change in this i mean you go
back to 30 years you know 30 years or 20
years that wouldn't have happened
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website well if you do then easy
dns are the company for you easy dns is
the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be council culture d
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows a bit about
that so will you in a second easy dns of
rock solid network infrastructure and
incredible customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you'd know about that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns right now all you've got to do
is head over to easydns.com forward
slash triggered and use our promo code
which is of course triggered as well and
you will get fifty percent off with the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy that tells you
everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
so there's been a big swing in public
opinion on this issue i haven't seen i'm
not sure exactly what the the surveys
are now in the in the uk if you know how
many people will be in favor of
legalizing marijuana here for a start
um but i think
there is a certain move with with
politicians but i do think
that politics has become very very
broken
and that and they're not
looking at like solving
practical issues a lot of the po it's
not like sitting down and saying i think
the spirit that's lasted for a long time
in the us in europe if we can solve
things we can solve problems we've lost
a lot of that
and and it's people now just like
posturing showing off their own kind of
social media followers
attacking the opposition
not really saying how can we actually
come together and find a real solution
to this problem do you not get
frustrated about this i mean you must be
surely you're covering this stuff just
absolute horror yeah for for what two
decades now yeah as long as you've been
yeah and you're seeing that you're
giving people information about what's
going on you talk about two million
people being murdered in latin america
and
no one seems to care
yeah absolutely i mean like uh
um
it's
i mean
it's been a crazy journey yeah and and
as well as
you know
there's some things that really strike
with me i spent a lot of time
interviewing cartel members
gangsters criminals
so it's spending a lot of time with with
with people who like serial murderers
um now i as a journalist feel i've got
you know it's important to talk to these
people
um to try and understand who they are i
mean what they're going through some of
them are evil or medieval acts some of
them you can you know i can get on or
you know one can get on okay with them
um you can find they've got nice sides
to them um this one guy i went out
drinking in a nightclub with him i
didn't really know quite how deep he was
in beforehand you know we did a big
bucket of beer kind of nice that seemed
like a nice guy when we sat down you
know did an interview with him
uh later and he was describing
butchering an entire family he was
describing decapitating people while
they're still alive which would be in
the contracts
um you know how they have that there
they decapitate them and you know how
their kind of bodies are reacting to
that
um later on he he was murdered
so you see this
um this stuff and is repeating repeating
repeating just keeps on going
um and yeah i mean i kind of think i had
a certain naivety when i went into this
and now i look back and read my first
book that i wrote
ten years ago
i had this kind of
optimism this we can solve this could be
changed
when i talk to a lot of people living in
these areas they don't have that
optimism
their their idea is this the way it is
there's violence um and i'm going to try
and make the best of this for myself
um they're not thinking oh how you know
how can we
change and move this situation
it is frustrating and i think we're
losing
um
i think a lot of the gains we've made
i mean you think there's got to be a way
to stop this you know if we can you know
if humans can put man on the moon
um all the things that we can do we can
create nuclear bombs
how can we have
you know in latin america right now in
some u.s cities
murder rates
which are
like 50 times london
so if you think linda london's bad at
stabbing imagine that times 50.
what that means when everybody
knows
several people who have been murdered
um what that means in terms of you don't
want your kid out by themselves
ever
because you're just scared that
something could happen
um that you're constantly got that edge
um on and we can't we can't stop that
stuff and even you compare it to like
medieval london it's the murder rates
right now it's in latin america it's a
five times six times
the rates that were in medieval london
so it's not like it's his natural state
of things that there should be this
level of violence
don't you think that part of the problem
as well is that we conflate drug taking
with morality
so you know that if you take drugs you
ultimately become immoral and if you're
immoral then you should be punished when
it's been proven time and time again
that
you know as long as there's going to be
human beings they're going to be taking
drugs we've taken drugs since time
immoral
yeah we have taken uh drugs since time
immoral i think there's this
differences in the drug taking um now
compared to some of like you know drug
taking before i mean things like the
fact you know there was um
we drink um you know alcohol now much
stronger alcohol than we people used to
drink you know to be like a week of beer
or whatever now it's like a week of wine
and now it's like now we're doing mezcal
and and vodka and that kind of thing um
you know a lot we've taken people took
um say
magic mushrooms
um in you know like druids took them
more people took me like ceremonies
before
but now people are just doing like
lines of coke and and just taking drugs
that kind of parties and people are kind
of so i think i think there's issues i
think there's quite big issues about
the nature of modern society i think the
nature of mental health yeah human
society and the way that like i mean
most people who become bad drug addicts
have got problems other problems not
just it's not like someone's super happy
everything's going great in their lives
and they become like a bad drug some
people take drugs recreationally they go
out they get drunk they take a few lines
and that's it they can leave it and they
can carry on some of them are like in
parliament or you know or like selling
stocks or whatever
um other people you know they they they
start taking them you know then they've
got a real big problem with this and
then they become like a bad addict and
then people die above those stuff
so we i think we've got to look at these
i think this gets into bigger issues and
it's kind of hard to solve but about
i think about about people about
separation about loneliness and about
all of these things we have to kind of
address as well yeah it's a really good
point i i wouldn't want this intimate to
come off as like us going oh yeah
everyone should be taking drugs and
there's nothing wrong with it at all
because we know that there's a lot of
problems that come with that uh but i
guess there's been a lot of written
about now that we know that the reason
people take drugs often is to do with
trauma it's to do with suffering some
kind of pain is to deal with difficulty
and yeah we've said okay you can take
alcohol and drink yourself to death and
that's okay but you can't take this
other stuff that to me is is really the
issue uh but um
you mentioned the aoc and the
conversation around
america's past behavior in latin america
yeah
uh
what has been the west's role in
in the war on drugs and the violence you
talk about in latin america has the west
helped
has the west made it worse like what has
been the impact of of the attempts to
intervene in one way or another yeah
sure so historically when you go back to
richard nixon
um before
then the us really pushed this so the
beginning like the u.s pushed um crop
spraying
in mexico it's going back to the 1970s
and started saying you got to like use
you know we'll give you and they'll say
we'll give you military helicopters and
you spray crops and so the military then
empowered and getting money to be
cracking down on drug production which
then just shifted so they actually began
in sinaloa they ran them out of search
and load they went to the second city
guadalajara just grew and grew in size
um crop spraying in colombia which they
never no never wiped out the cocaine
trade you know you just spray crops
spray spray spray it's whack-a-mole you
know you're going bang bang bang and
this is all there's springing up all the
time
so the u.s i mean the u.s was pressuring
as a policy so these have a thing called
certification where they certified
countries by how much they were cracking
down on drugs supposedly they had this
idea this would work and it would stop
drug trafficking and it failed
um so the u.s you know did this and
pushed this for a long time
um
now it i say now it's kind of a zombie
war on drugs now it doesn't now this
thing's just like carrying on moving the
drug trade is there there's billions and
billions of dollars in it people just
carry on doing it
you've also got which my third book
looks at the the traffic of firearms so
now the united states has the biggest
firearms market in the world by far the
last count or estimate was 393 million
guns in civilian hands which is more the
next 25 countries combined
from that you have like a legal firearms
market you have a parallel black market
from this parallel black market you have
guns flowing down well moving around to
the gangs in the united states you know
all around the us but also flowing down
to mexico um the last 12 years you've
seen more than 160 000 firearms taken
from cartels in mexico and definitively
traced to u.s
gun shops and gun stores the real
numbers are believed to be more than 200
000 guns every year going down there so
this is trafficking historic case of
trafficking to heavy i'm confident which
is again is why i think i mean are
americans and some of these politicians
they do not know about that
um some of these politicians who are
talking
in you know in congress they not know
about these things or are they not
interested in in real solutions
to this stuff right now well there was a
scandal wasn't there it was operation
fast and furious yeah exactly tell
everybody a little bit about what
happened yeah so fast and furious was an
operation by the american gun police
called the bureau of alcohol tobacco
farms and explosives
in 2009
2010 it blew open in 2011 well 2011 it
really came out the public
um and what it was was that the atf
agents were watching
people cartel affiliates
buy guns and traffic them to the cartels
the plan was we're going to watch them
they tried to get some chips in the gun
so they could trace them
and we can build up a big conspiracy
case to kind of bring down the whole
racket
they ended up watching 2000 guns be
trafficked to to mexico
one of them was found in the last safe
house of el chapo some of them got them
bounced down to colombia
and then one of them was later used to
murder a an american border patrol agent
in the united states
um which then when it really blew up
um and they just you know so they were
like basically complicit in this
there was one guy who walked in the shop
spent half a million dollars on guns
they were just watching him do it
um
there was you know it was a kind of
crazy crazy scheme
now this
cut you know the politics is cut
different ways and i'm trying to like
you know bring this you know left-wing
right-wing whatever i think on the drugs
issue a lot of left and right can really
come together on this issue
um
i think we've got i think on the actual
issue of guns themselves more divisive
in the united states yeah but this issue
actually was owned by conservatives
because it happened under obama
under attorney general eric holder and
so it became like this is what the obama
administration has done and the kind of
conspiracy they want to do this to kind
of take away our guns in mexico it's
more of a conspiracy of saying well look
the us wants us to be violent they're
like they're like deliberately they're
involved in trafficking the guns to us
they're watching this happen
so yeah it cuts it cuts you know all
kinds of ways well the thing is you
don't have to be anti-gun to be
anti-trafficking guns to mexican drug
laws
you can be pro-gun as well but also want
them to be legally controlled and none
of this to happen right yeah exactly and
i interviewed one um confidential
informant who was a gun seller and he
was that he was he was a gun seller and
he was
saying i don't want these guns going to
cartels and he was actually ended up you
know being you know with a hidden
recorder um taping conversations with
with cartel affiliates and then at the
end he was like none of us came to
anything i was just doing this
and none of us came to anything and then
he was making money i mean he was making
money both getting paid by the
government to be a confidential
informant and making money from the gun
sales
just sounds like a broken system man
yeah yeah and you say we've got a zombie
war on drugs you know it's a broken
system isn't it because we've kind of
admitted that there is no solution to
this problem really
yeah i mean like i think you know
politics is broken and you know we've
got to try and you know
bring the conversation on now like i
think a lot of people now probably most
of you as i'd imagine
would be in favor of legalizing
marijuana as a guess
um
when you get to cocaine some people get
like you know you know or someone's you
know suffering or people like seeing
like
like in the us now you know they've got
loads of homeless people on the streets
who are taking drugs so you think well
decriminalization isn't working there's
allowing them to be doing you know like
just sitting there taking drugs on the
streets um what we're going to do about
them they know that these people need
help a lot of them but also i think you
know you've got another discussion about
law enforcement
so i think on the one side i think we
need drug policy reform on the other
side we do need to take law enforcement
very seriously in terms of stopping
anti-social crime an anti-social crime i
mean in in latin america i mean
violently anti-social disappearances
uh i mean um
rapes and and i mean i
there i mean there's a very um
aggressive feminist movement in in in
mexico and latin america but then
they've got these grievances of like you
know horrific you know every day you see
a woman's being
raped and murdered in their body left i
interviewed one woman who was this is
going down to central america
and she was gang raped
by the members of the
ms-13 gang
and it was kind of used to use the
weapon of conflict of violence against
people
so these kind of kind of anti-social
crimes and violence and in import
communities are the ones that suffer
most from this
um everywhere we are and we need to take
this stuff very very seriously and say
how do we have law enforcement for that
at the same time as saying
actually on drug issue itself we need to
rethink this and just lock everyone up
for this or just you know allowing an
illegal black market in drugs which
generates money which gives an incentive
for people to have guns
and and fight over this you know this is
not working
do you think part of the solution could
be though joanne is that
look
the we've all our governments have spent
a phenomenal amount of money on covid
and they're looking around they think
right we need to regenerate it you know
we need to regenerate we need to think
of ways to make more money
let's be fair if you want to monetize
something marijuana is the best way to
do it isn't it yeah absolutely and and
you've seen
um big incomes you know being generated
in cities that have legalized marijuana
um and a lot of people in that business
and if it did happen in the uk i'm sure
like you know you get some of the same
old
um you know
networks soon jumping into that and you
know where the spoons yeah where the
spoons are you know the friends of boris
johnson whatever you know business you
know who like jumping into another you
know be a big thing to invest in if it's
only like opening like you know
marijuana dispensaries around the uk
um sure
there's a lot there's a lot of money in
this absolutely i mean if you've got um
an industry that's i mean again these
numbers are pure estimates or
guesstimates but you know there was a un
thing took about 300 billion dollars
globally
and that's 300 billion dollars you know
governments can tax or know whatever no
no not all of it you know say you know
there's some drugs maybe we can
i mean i don't know if heroin you can
ever
allow
people to go to the shop and buy heroin
but the thing is this
this conversation doesn't need to be had
in this way does it because when we talk
about decriminalizing things let's say
we're not saying you can go into a
pharmacy and buy a kilo of heroin what
we're saying is if you if you are a user
of heroin instead of putting you in
prison yeah uh we
we make sure you get the treatment that
you need which is rehab which is
psychological help to deal with your
underlying issues i don't think anyone's
advocating that these really really
damaging drugs like cocaine heroin etc
should just be freely available at a you
know just to whoever wants them i think
there's got to be some nuance in the
conversation yeah i think marijuana is
something you could probably legalize
but other drugs may be just
decriminalized they've done that in
portugal i think in switzerland to some
extent with heroin as well there's
places in the world that have found a
way of doing this it doesn't have to be
like
free-for-all you know
well yeah but there still leaves a
problem though because when you
um if you decriminalize heroin so we
decriminalize heroin in the uk
um and let's say people spend and just
just just out there like we have a
billion pounds on heroin
so they're not gonna arrest people who
are like um who are
just having this
being caught with the bits they're
heroin users
but it's still going to be a black
market illegal trade providing them yeah
so you still then got the gangs you know
moving the heroin and making money from
it and having the violence and you've
still got the cartels or whatever i mean
here everyone comes from say but i think
in switzerland
what they do though is they give them
the herald yeah so yeah that's another
step so that's another thing you could
look at where you have government
programs and you have things like
methadone as well there's other
other like substitutes yeah so we like
expanding those kind of programs now
again it's still difficult when you get
into this because you have you know you
might have somebody who's like get some
you know scripts you know from the
government right um and then sells those
and now somebody remember back when i
was in in the 80s early 90s remember
people doing that like get scripts for
pills call them like jellies or
something something like pills and then
i said they're not reselling them on the
street and stuff so it's difficult as
well um but i think some of these we
have you know has a look at this stuff
we have to try and find ways i think one
way to see this and a lot of problems
is rather than you know these absolutist
things of saying like you know which
richard nixon nixon when he began the
war and drugs said we will banish heroin
from american life
we're not going to get rid of it
completely
but we've got to reduce the harm reduce
the damage
so if the illegal drug money right now
is you know over 150 billion dollars in
the united states
if you can reduce that by half
then that's 75 billion dollars less
going to
organize crime
um if you can reduce it by two-thirds so
if you can try and see
a reduction in this and reduce the
number of people dying of of overdoses
rather than saying we're going to get
rid of this problem completely
uh you know we've got a few minutes left
so
obviously whenever you talk about this
issue it's not a positive conversation
just given the nature of what we're
talking about here right but do you
think there's um
any reason to be positive any any reason
for optimism around this issue do you
think
there's any delight at the end of the
tunnel here or do you think this is just
an issue that's not going to get better
in the foreseeable
um yeah i try and be optimistic and not
really pessimistic about stuff i don't
know i don't like the idea of uh
of pessimistic views on the world and
stuff
um and i mean there's a lot of things
driving a particular violence in mexico
so it's not
the drugs are in a way
you know you could talk about mexico as
being rather than the mexican war and
drugs the mexican drug war which is a
war being partly financed by drugs you
know they're financing an armed conflict
and maybe it's going to last you know a
few years more and finally kind of can't
calm down
and and it's also about finding
governability finding police forces that
can work in that which i think is a
bigger issue as well
across the world is like how you have
you know how you create law enforcement
that works a lot of countries don't have
functional law enforcement
um you know it's something else we you
know we can easily take for granted and
there's a lot of problems with law
enforcement in the uk but it's a hell of
a lot better than
many many countries and you know the
levels of violence here
are better but like
i put if you look at a positive solution
or positive take
on this
i mean yeah i mean public opinion has
changed massively on this issue like
generation wise things have changed
so
you know people started taking drugs in
a really big way i think in the west
from the 60s onwards that was when it
kind of really blew up when i was
growing up in the 80s
there was all just drugs already
everywhere
so we're growing up around drugs then
um and probably the same for for you
know the new generation now they've got
i think maybe even less drug taking now
than there was in the 80s 90s i don't
you know i don't know exactly it's hard
to know
so you get more used to it and then you
get like less you know now it's kind of
if people often people who are the most
scared about drugs and the kind of old
idea of the kind of you know the old um
war on drug stuff or the real fear
um there was a film from the 1930s in
the states of 94 it's called reefer
madness yeah i've seen it
i watched it when i was high yeah
it is a classic yeah these people like a
guy in a suit and tie and he smokes
marijuana and then they smoke some weed
and he's just
losing it
um
but now those have changed so i think i
think we've got the the change in a big
change in public opinion it's about i
think now it's about taking that and
making that to actual change in policies
jan it's been a wonderful wonderful
interview uh before we do our questions
for locals the last question we always
ask is uh what's the one thing we're not
talking about but we really should be
yeah yeah i i i tried to think of this
before to me it was hard work or i think
can you give away the secrets of the
game which means to be off the cuff yeah
i know off the cuff okay i was trying to
think about this but anyway the um
it's almost like everything's being
talked about i think but i think one
issue which is um
um
talked about but i think could come more
and i see this coming back to england
is the kind of over
digitalization of everything
i think the way particularly england's
become such
a digital society
and it's in some parts of life where we
don't need it um you know like going to
a pub and having to go on an app to
order a drink
instead of being able to go to a bar and
i understand the health stuff there but
like this idea that everything's online
that every bank has to like close down
its branches that you can't you know
talk to a doctor anymore you have to go
like and send emails i think this is
fracturing society more um i think one
of the big challenges now is
i mean it's also of all of us you know
how we're trying to get a balance
between digital life
and you know in real life and really
seeing people and stuff and i think
that's one of the things we need to talk
about more um that's a really good point
john and for those of you watching we
can ask some questions in fact your
questions from locals so join locals
check out our page there and you'll be
able to submit questions for our future
guests and read the answers uh but yeah
in the meantime thank you for coming on
blood gun money is your latest book
everyone should get it of course i look
forward to reading your back catalogue
as well because it's just this is an
issue i really find very interesting um
and thank you for coming on the show
where should people go to check out your
work and follow the latest in what
you're doing yeah sure so i've got a
weird name that's easy to find ion first
name and grillo gri-lo so it's just just
you can just search for that but you can
see i've got a website you angrily.com
i'm on twitter
um some of the time
not too much from my digital thing but
you can see that a bit of stuff on
youtube as well you can check out
um and you can see my in a bunch of
media outlets i have my store as well
fantastic thanks for coming on man and
thank you all for watching we will see
you very soon with another brilliant
episode and they always go out episodes
and raw shows 7 p.m uk time tuesday to
sunday or 2 p.m eastern eastern standard
time take care and see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below